[Musica]
avete mai pensato al paesaggio come a
una scultura
avete mai pensato che una casa un albero
possano avere una propria personalità
una propria identità
avete mai immaginato che un luogo possa
avere una sua anima
ecco oggi vorrei portarvi con me in
questa dimensione immateriale per
raccontarvi come sono arrivato a
realizzare delle opere in grado di
dialogare con quello che gli antichi
romani chiamavano il genius loci ossia
lo spirito del luogo
sono nato e cresciuto a cambiago un
paesino dell'hinterland milanese ha
cambiato tra una rotonda una superstrada
una palazzina anni settanta spuntano qua
e là dei castelli dei cascinotti
diroccati alcuni mangiati dalla natura
altri hanno un albero che spunta dal
tetto quasi completamente caduto queste
dimensioni sospese risultano i miei
occhi come una sorta di come una sorta
di isolette sacra in mezzo a contrasto
con l'urbanizzazione che nel frattempo
si mangia tutto il resto del territorio
in questo contesto inizio ad
appassionarmi ad incuriosirmi del
paesaggio dei linguaggi del paesaggio ed
alla sacralità che vive in alcuni luoghi
nel frattempo finisco gli studi
all'istituto d'arte di monza e mi
trasferisco a vent'anni a roma dove
iniziò a lavorare come scenografo in
vari campi tra arte e cinema nel 2013
un amico mi invita
a partecipare a un festival di arte
urbana in calabria e io accetto spinto
anche da dall'istinto e dall'idea dal
desiderio di voler ritornare a parlare
di paesaggi e di natura arrivo e
realizza la mia prima scultura la figura
di un uomo seduto su un muretto che
guarda il mare
voi vi chiederete cosa c'entra un uomo
seduto su un muro con il paesaggio la
natura è l'idea era quella di raccontare
una storia semplice una storia quasi
invisibile e quindi decido di utilizzare
la rete metallica e la trasparenza per
riuscire a realizzare un'opera che
sapesse inserirsi nel luogo in maniera
timida solo che scopro che in realtà la
trasparenza aveva un potenziale molto
più grande aveva la capacità di
raccontare luogo attraverso di sé perché
il paesaggio disegnava gli stati d'animo
della figura e la luce del sole
cambiando raccontava i diversi stati
emotivi sempre del personaggio così mi
rendo conto che il paesaggio in realtà
era la vera essenza di cui era fatta la
mia prima opera dopo l'esperienza in
calabria decido di lasciare il mio
lavoro come come scenografo e inizia a
lavorare in studio realizzando una serie
di sculture e iniziò anche a girare in
italia e all'estero realizzando delle
opere d arte pubblica delle grandi opere
d'arte pubblica come era stato per la
prima dopo un periodo di ricerca
realizzo a londra control con control
presento ufficialmente il concetto di
materia assente ossia utilizzo la rete e
la trasparenza per rappresentare la
materia assente che il lato i materiali
delle cose
il mio percorso continua poi iniziò ad
alternare alle figure delle geometrie
dei piani dei cubi degli elementi
geometrici e iniziò a realizzare delle
installazioni che creano dei volumi che
non escludono il paesaggio ma lo
includono valorizzandolo inizio poi a
immaginare di realizzare delle
architetture nel paesaggio in cui
l'orizzonte delimita il pavimento le
montagne entrano nelle pareti ed alle
volte le nuvole decidono quanto siamo
lontani dal cielo così in inghilterra
realizza la mia prima cupola e se negli
archetipi classici la cupola rappresenta
la volta celeste
la mia architettura è la volta celeste
la materia di cui sono fatte e inizia
utilizzare il linguaggio
dell'architettura classica per
raccontare la sacralità dei luoghi che
tanto ricercavo fino a prima
con la nuova tecnica le dimensioni delle
istallazioni crescevano le avevo
finalmente la possibilità veramente di
generare dei mondi inimmaginabili così
passa del tempo io continuo a lavorare
finalmente arriva la commissione il
lavoro che mi avrebbe permesso di
concretizzare tutta una serie di
riflessioni fatte sul paesaggio sul
luogo sulla sacralità del luogo che è
siponto siponto per chi non la
conoscesse è una piccola località vicino
a manfredonia in puglia il parco
archeologico di siponto che questo che
vedete custodiva le fondamenta di un
antica basilica paleocristiana che
scomparsa quasi mille anni fa
così attraverso la trasparenza
ricostruisco
attraverso la trasparenza ricostruisco
la basilica sparita la riporto
attraverso la sua essenza la sua
dimensione più eterea una chiesa sospesa
nel tempo che mostra principalmente la
sua assenza raccontando la sua storia no
il fatto che che fosse sparita e al
tempo stesso esprime l'identità e la
sacralità del luogo in cui è stato fatto
l'intervento
il progetto siponto oltre a essere oltre
a essere un progetto inedito è il frutto
di una visione che ha cercato di
raccontare il paesaggio oltre quello che
vediamo oltre quello che percepiamo e
quando un progetto alla capacità di
essere pioniere nel suo campo riesce a
generare dei nuovi contenuti e delle
nuove prospettive siponto ha generato
delle nuove prospettive e campi
dell'arte pubblica nel restauro nello
sviluppo del territorio nella
valorizzazione del paesaggio e del
patrimonio ed è riuscito a farlo perché
ha cercato di raccontare il patrimonio
il paesaggio attraverso un'esperienza
emotiva attraverso la sacralità di un
luogo attraverso la poesia
principalmente quindi tornando a noi che
cosa significa pensare al paesaggio come
una scultura che cosa significa scolpire
il paesaggio
beh scolpire il paesaggio significa fare
di un luogo un'opera d'arte viva che
respira e si evolve con gli elementi del
luogo
scolpire il paesaggio significa generare
un'esperienza in grado di metterci in
connessione con l'identità ma anche con
la sacralità del luogo
io penso che l'arte abbia la capacità di
raccontare questo tipo di storia penso
che l'arte abbia la capacita e deve
avere la capacità di raccontare la
poetica di un luogo perché l'arte
attraverso la poesia può darci delle
chiavi di lettura che la sola logica non
ci può dare
grazie mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]